[російською] Ну так, це наше село. Прекрасне наше село.
[російською] Якщо озирнутись довкола,
цілком на видноті весь Ай-Серез.
[російською] Це гора, відома гора, я вже не пам'ятаю її назви.
[російською] У кримських татар є назви
для кожної вершини, для кожного пагорба.
[російською] Десь близько 72 найменувань.
[російською] Очевидно, що всі назви я не пам'ятаю.
[російською] Але ця найвідоміша.
[російською] Вона видніється з того дому, який нам належав,
нашого родового дому в Ай-Серезі,
[російською] звідки розкуркулювали,
відправляли на Урал моїх батьків.
[російською] Вони звідти, на щастя, втекли.
[російською] Але повертатись в Крим одразу не стали.
Приїхали в Мелітополь.
[російською] А потім все ж таки перебралися до Криму,
але в рідне село не повертались, тому що могли донести НКВС.
[російською] І вони поселились в Фрайдорфському районі,
це північний Крим.
[російською] Село Бозкой, і я там народився.
[російською] 1944 року депортували нас з Криму саме з села Бозкой.
[російською] По-моєму, це та мечеть, яка була зруйнована,
[російською] а потім силами наших співгромадян —
відновлена, у міру їх можливостей.
[російською] І ми звідси, з Києва, надавали
певну допомогу у відновленні цієї мечеті.
[російською] Коли я був тут, а це було десь 2010 року, здається,
[російською] тут був узагалі жахливий стан,
напівзруйнована будівля, а зараз дещо відновили.
[російською] Ай-Серез я відвідав тільки вже 1989 року.
Це рік мого повернення в Крим.
[російською] А потім щорічно, як і у всіх селах Криму,
[російською] кримські татари влаштовували
в один день на рік День рідного села.
[російською] Я майже щороку приїжджав до цього села,
зустрічався зі співвітчизниками.
[російською] І, звісно, відвідував будинок своїх батьків.
[російською] Схоже на те, що це мій батьківський дім.
[російською] Щоправда, давно,
дуже давно не заходив я сюди.
[російською] Дім начебто непоказний, але в ті часи,
[російською] часи розкуркулення,
мабуть, він вважався великим.
[російською] Там десь 1,5 поверхи.
[російською] А за радянськими мірками вважалося,
що це велика розкіш, яка підлягала розкуркуленню.
[російською] Одразу, звісно, постало питання
про те, аби викупити цей дім.
[російською] Хоча би в пам'ять про своїх батьків.
[російською] Планували його відреставрувати, відремонтувати
[російською] і зробити якусь
базу відпочинку для наших співвітчизників.
[російською] Проте не вдалося.
[російською] Окупація з 2014 року.
[російською] Фонд «Крим» і все його майно арештували.
[російською] І зараз воно під арештом.
[російською] А потім був заборонений
і Меджліс кримськотатарського народу.
[російською] І зараз цей дім у такому «підвішеному» стані.
[російською] Нічого собі! Усе наше село.
[із захопленням в голосі]
[російською] Така щемна туга...
[російською] Я одразу згадую, де ми там
разом зі співвітчизниками ходили тими ущелинами...
[російською] Люди старшого віку тоді розповідали мені, хто і де жив,
[російською] що з ними сталося: кого розстріляли,
кого депортували і де він помер,
[російською] як називаються ці вершини, ці гори...
[російською] Ось так.
[російською] Нічого собі!